[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 en
Iran les manifestations se poursuivent
dans de nombreuses villes du pays elles
n'ont pas cessé depuis le décès de Marsa
à mini âgé de 22 ans après son
arrestation par la police des mœurs
athéhéran pour port de vêtements non
appropriés des femmes ont jeté leur
voile dans les flammes dans une ville au
nord-est de la capitale à Sarry au total
selon les ONG au moins 31 personnes sont
mortes dans des affrontements avec la
police 17 selon la télévision d'État la
répression ne faiblit pas en ce sixième
jour de protestation les autorités ont
bloqué l'accès à Instagram et à WhatsApp
Washington sanctionne maintenant la
police des mœurs iraniennes alors que
révèle ces manifestations de la société
iranienne pourrait-elle venir à bout
d'un régime préoccupé par la succession
du Guide suprême rally ramenei la
répression sert-elle le régime dans un
Iran qui reste influent au Liban en Irak
ou encore en Syrie et bien on va en
débattre avec mes invités plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés rezvan zaedy bonsoir
vous êtes photographe iranienne réfugiés
politiques en France depuis 2015 et
votre travail artistique porte
d'ailleurs sur le corps des femmes
bienvenue à vous en face de vous Farid
Vahid bonsoir directeur de
l'observatoire de l'Afrique du Nord et
du Moyen-Orient de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès bienvenue à vous également en
face David Rigoulet rose bonsoir
chercheur associé à l'Institut de
recherche internationale et stratégique
rédacteur en chef de la revue Orient
stratégique et vous avez co-dirigé
l'ouvrage la République islamique d'Iran
en crise systémique quatre décennies de
tourment aux éditions l'Harmattan
bienvenue David rigoloz dans le débat en
face de vous on la connaît tous bien sûr
Mariam Mariam kerzaden notre ancienne
correspondante en Iran journaliste à
France 24 donc bien sûr spécialiste de
l'Iran bonsoir Mariam bonsoir vous
pouvez tous réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux hashtag débats F24 Marsa Amini
on le sait maintenant c'était une
iranienne originaire du Kurdistan et
c'est la police des mœurs en Iran qu'il
a arrêté le 13 septembre à Téhéran pour
port de vêtements inappropriés il s'agit
d'une unité chargée de faire respecter
le code vestimentaire stricte de la
République islamique d'Iran Marsa mini
est morte 3 jours après à l'hôpital
alors quel est le rôle de cette police
des mœurs bilates
sur cette vidéo les deux femmes voilées
de noir font partie de la police des
mœurs iranienne elles essaient d'obliger
la femme voilée en rouge à s'asseoir son
ami au voile vert tente de l'aider la
femme désormais au sol crie cela fait 30
ans que vous nous oppressez
sur cette autre vidéo cette fois c'est
une foule qui tente de s'interposer
entre la police des mœurs et une femme
non voilée pour empêcher son arrestation
il y a sur internet des dizaines de
vidéos d'altercation entre la population
iranienne et la police des mœurs relayée
par des journalistes iraniens et des ONG
créé au lendemain de la Révolution
islamique la police des mœurs s'est
appelée dans le pays gâche et hershad
c'est à dire patrouille d'orientation
son rôle est de vérifier que les femmes
respectent les règles vestimentaires en
vigueur les cheveux couverts
l'interdiction de porter des manteaux
courts des pantalons serrés ou bien des
jeans troués la police des mœurs c'est
plus ou moins puissante en fonction du
président en place modéré ou
conservateur elle patrouille en voiture
conduite par des hommes les femmes étant
chargées des arrestations la mort de
Massa mini a relancé la colère de la
population contre cette police
j'ai peur quand je la vois la police des
mœurs ne devrait pas exister la police
des mœurs devrait être définitivement
supprimée parce que son comportement
avec nous n'est pas correct c'est rare
un député iranien a exprimé à une agence
de presse ces critique la police des
mœurs n'obtient aucun résultat sauf
causer des dommages au pays le principal
problème c'est que certaines personnes
ne veulent pas voir la vérité selon une
ONG iranienne pour les droits humains la
police d'émerce présente à la justice
plus de 16000 femmes par an pour non
respect des règles vestimentaires mais
aussi lorsqu'elle se promène avec un ami
[Musique]
le voile il tombe de plus en plus rezvan
Zaidi vous vous avez été exilé donc vous
avez été arrêté vous par la police des
mœurs là-bas je pense que pas sauf moi
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de femmes
Iraniens qui a cette expérience même
pour une fois dans leur vie mais vous ça
vous est arrivé oui et quand elle vous
arrête elle vous emmène au poste donc
comment ça se passe elle est la première
fois que c'est police c'est gâcheté
airshot qui m'a arrêté c'était fan de
l'âge de 19 ans ils ont arrêté ils ont
ma ramené chez eux et ils ont fait un
dossier pour moi et après c'est l'autre
main qui c'est eux qui m'a envoyé à
tribunal pour faire le dossier que
pourquoi j'avais
voile coloré et le manteau un petit peu
le courte et j'étais obligée de
expliquer devant le juge que moi je ne
suis pas coupable même qui avait
vraiment
forcé sur moi que tu as cassé le doigt
et ça ce n'est pas une loi islamique que
c'est eux qui m'a arrêté vraiment
quelque chose pour juste on voit le
coloré oui
il font partie en fait du système c'est
ça en fait ils incarne le régime ils en
sont le symbole je dirais le plus
visible justement ça fait partie de
l'ADN du système et même si avec le
président réformiste c'est tout à fait
vrai qu'ils sont moins visibles
peut-être moins agressif mais le
problème c'est que le président
réformiste que ça soit retami il a été
débutant au pouvoir au rouani ils n'ont
pas pu finalement débarrasser de la
progression iranienne de cette police et
cette petite pour ça aussi que la
journée soit aujourd'hui est très en
colère parce que finalement on se pose
la question de la réforme est-ce que le
système est réformable on a eu des
réformes ce pouvoir eux ils sont
toujours là et à chaque fois on a
l'impression de prendre peut-être un pas
en avant mais de pas en arrière c'est
sûr que les filles aujourd'hui ne sont
pas du tout voilà comme les années 80
ils ont pu avancer et l'ont arraché
elle-même mais en fait le voile en Iran
c'est le symbole aussi de la République
islamique une république religieuse
théologique et le gâcheté l'eau chaude
faut plutôt traduire une police de la
guidance islamique c'est pour les femmes
pour leur imposer un mode de vie
islamique c'est pour les hommes aussi
vous pouvez pas vous balader en short en
Iran quand vous êtes un homme vous
pouvez pas être voilà sous alcool donc
c'est vraiment pour imposer cette mode
de vie islamique et ça fait partie bien
évidemment de l'ADN du système est-ce
qu'ils peuvent arrêter aussi des coupes
qui ne sont mariés en fait on est
complètement à la merci c'est ça c'est
arbitraire c'est si jamais ils ont
décidé que ils veulent faire du zèle ou
que la tenue de leur convient pas on est
complètement à merci de cette tous les
jours mais ça peut arriver tous les
jours à tout le monde est-ce que vous
avez été surpris par la mort de cette
jeune fille justement parce que
finalement elle a été arrêtée d'abord
par cette police des mœurs et ensuite
elle est morte à l'hôpital on ne sait
pas ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs entre
les deux il y a une brutalité c'est
choquant une jeune fille de 22 ans qui
qui vient à la capitale et qui est
assassiné comme ça sans aucune raison
bon de toute évidence elle a reçu des
coups par la police tant qu'elle est on
sait qu'elle est assassinée elle a pas
fait une crise cardiaque comme le dit le
régime et c'est complètement choquant
c'est pour ça que je pense que ça touche
des millions d'Iraniens de classe
différentes que ça soit de classer
favorisé ou bourgeoise toutes les villes
en néant de toutes les régions les gens
sont dans la rue parce que ça a
complètement choqué toute la population
iranienne David Rigoulet rose vous voyez
vous qui connaissez quand même très bien
la région une différence entre la
mobilisation actuelle qu'on voit sur les
réseaux et auparavant comme il y en a
plus y avoir en 2020 ou 2020 il me
semble qu'il y avait vraiment eu très
peur 2017
oui c'est assez différent et c'est
singulier parce que on touche peut-être
quelque chose de central là finalement
avec cette question du voile le paradoxe
d'ailleurs c'est que le régime alors
qu'il y a un écart qui se creuse entre
sa population et et les autorités il
fait montre d'un excès de de zèle
puisque le 5 juillet dernier il y a eu
un renforcement justement de la loi sur
décennies et le l'écart se creuse avec
ceux qui gouvernent et qui comprennent
pas ce qui se passe Farid il y a
effectivement une différence avec 2020
oui ce qui est intéressant en fait c'est
que ça conservateur là qui sont pouvoir
actuellement ils savent très bien que la
majorité des Iraniens ne veulent pas de
pourquoi ils font ça parce qu'elle pense
à leur base à la minorité qui soutient
le régime et cette minorité là elle
existe et le régime fait tout ça pour
eux pour leur dire on vous entend on a
peut-être pas la majorité mais on voit
votre soutien c'est pour ça que grâce
ici hier à New York qui prend le
portrait du général sol et monis pour
parler à eux par cette base là pas aux
autres iraniens quand justement vous
voyez ça vous rezvan Zaidi vous avez fui
le pays et vous êtes exilé donc vous ce
que vous avez vu c'est ça c'est le
régime c'est cette privation de liberté
vous ne pouviez pas vous exprimer par
exemple faire les photos que vous
souhaitiez c'était ça la raison de votre
départ
parce que
quand j'ai dit que quand j'étais en Iran
plusieurs fois c'est OK qui m'a arrêté
le police de casterschad et après moi
j'ai commencé de
prendre une manifestation par avec le
photo parce que j'ai réussi que moi si
je continue je viens contrer aussi ok
qui va finalement va me tuer parce que
pour les cachères ça c'est la même chose
très facile et moi j'ai commencé de
photographie
graffiti dans la rue j'ai dit comme ça
j'ai une façon pour que mes photos
viennent parler à ma place et après en
2015 moi je suis invitée par anisso de
mondara pour montrer les photos de
graffiti en haut et après
non maintenant depuis 7 ans que je suis
en france et je suis en exil je ne peux
pas rentrer et
ce qui se passe en ce moment toutes ces
manifestations toutes ces femmes
d'ailleurs qui avaient courage brûlent
leur
je suis très contente c'est vraiment
choquant et triste pour moi quand je
veux que il y a une femme
s'empêcher sans
une coupe sans qu'il soit coupable il
mord tout ça viendrait vraiment une
triste pour moi mais il y a une chose
que je suis contente que
au demande pour leur liberté et
l'égalité et je suis fière de toutes les
femmes et hommes qui sont dans la rue
pour changer cette régime Mariam et puis
malgré la répression parce que là on
parle il y a une trentaine de morts
selon les ONG 17 selon ce que dit la
télévision iranienne en tout cas la
répression est-ce qu'il y a peut-être
plus forte même que en 2020 ce qu'on a
un peu cette impression en finalement
même pas six jours c'est exactement le
même modus operandi que les autres
crises moi les derniers moi j'ai plus du
tout de contact là avec mes proches à
Téhéran il y a plus internet donc les
deux
WhatsApp et Instagram programme qui est
vraiment un vecteur de communication
donc j'ai ça fait j'ai eu quelques
nouvelles ce matin et ça s'est recoupé
de nouveau mais moi ce qu'on me dit
c'est que tous les soirs au moment les
manifestations commencent il y a les
nylos la police qui convergent vers le
centre de Téhéran de partout
certaines personnes me disent qu'il n'y
a pas que des Iraniens dans ces dans ces
brigades qui sont renforcées
quoi d'autre que des Iraniens donc on me
parle d'afghan de deux personnes qui
seraient extérieures c'est moi c'est
c'est je sais pas si vous avez un peu de
malade des forces extérieures qui qui
viendraient prêter main forte à la
police iranienne ce sont des amandes
noires qui se déploient massivement
c'est exactement la même la même
stratégie qu'en 2017
2018-2019-2020 on coupe internet on
essaie de couper l'Iran du monde couper
pour que les vidéos ne sortent pas
d'Iran et puis bah mater la mater les
manifestations dans une répression là
les chiffres qu'on a honnêtement c'est
des chiffres qui sont loin des réalités
sous-estimé très sous-espace mais par
rapport à non parce que on entend
le soir les moi ce qu'on me rapporte
c'est des sons d'ambulance c'est des
tirs ils tirent à balle réel sur les
manifestants pas partout mais il y a des
tirs à balles réelles sur les
manifestants on a enterré on a enterré
une jeune fille à calmant de chat et
dans durant ces funérailles il y avait
des slogans anti République islamiques
très fort donc on va regarder d'ailleurs
une carte Farid vide d'après ce que j'ai
dans ce qu'on entend dire c'est que
c'est plutôt dans le Nord qui a eu
plutôt des morts dans le Nord et
également dans la zone du Kurdistan
c'est ça aussi l'ouest dans le nord de
l'Iran Téhéran bouge beaucoup le centre
du pays aussi après faut dire aussi à la
différence des autres manifestations
certes le régime ils ont la même
tactique mais moi ce qui me fera que
c'est ce qui me frappe c'est de voir le
courage des Iraniens qui recule pas
cette fois-ci en 2009 des gens reculer
vraiment parce qu'on se souvient
quand la police arrive forcément vous
avez peur et aujourd'hui on voit des
jeunes de 20 à 21 ans 22 ans qui sautent
sur des voitures de police c'est le
force de l'ordre qui recule et ça c'est
aussi une frustration qui a été acc
jamais au fur et à mesure des années
pour plusieurs raisons mais le peuple
est vraiment en colère aujourd'hui donc
là ça risque de durer plus longtemps il
y aura des plus d'affrontements enfin
c'est ça que vous pensez que la
répression sera aussi probablement
beaucoup plus sanglante on va regarder
justement cette carte si on peut l'avoir
parce qu'on voit justement la ville dont
vient également cette jeune fille donc
qui a été Marsa à mini qui vient donc du
Kurdistan on le disait on ne la voit
plus mais bref il y a cette ville est-ce
que est-ce que ça a une importance le
fait qu'elle soit du Kurdistan David
Rigoulet rose ou pas
oui parce que le Kurdistan est quand
même une région très sensible pour le
pouvoir central ça l'a toujours été et
donc il y a une spécificité par rapport
à Téhéran mais c'est pas cantonné au
Kurdistan parce que ça arrive c'est une
maison d'arrêt donc c'est c'est rien à
voir avec le Kurdistan et pourtant c'est
là où il y a eu la fameuse vidéo
donc ça c'est au nord c'est au
nord-ouest
qui brûle les portraits de la du Guide
suprême aussi et puis c'est pas
forcément accidentel c'est une zone
ancienne de culture zorastrienne donc
avec la culture du feu etc il y a un
côté cathartique dans la vidéo qui a de
qui donc c'est assez intéressant et pour
revenir sur le par rapport aux autres
années aux autres événements en 2017
là on a le sentiment que c'est plus
trans classe sociale c'est à dire que
c'est moins segmenté socialement que ça
ne l'était en 2017 il y avait eu la
hausse de du prix de l'essence qui
touchait une catégorie particulière
etc et là manifestement c'est une
couleur qui gronde qui est profonde qui
traverse toutes les couches de la
société et c'est et donc c'est c'est
probablement un moment important pour
pour l'histoire de la République
islamique d'Iran donc ça n'est pas
simplement une révolte sociale non plus
même s'il y a une très forte inflation
en Iran même si j'imagine qu'il y a une
contestation liée à la société
politique c'est une crise politique
on voit toutes les villes et en 2019
c'était après l'augmentation du prix du
carburant donc c'était les zones
défavorisées en 2009 c'était l'électorat
de Milo saignosavie qui contestait la
réélection demain moderne aujourd'hui
c'est tous les Iraniens jeunes âgés des
grandes villes de la campagne aisé moins
aisés et c'est là que c'est très fort
c'est très symbolique mais ça peut faire
aussi très peur au régime donc la
répression aussi sera probablement très
forte aussi beaucoup plus forte
peut-être même qu'à l'époque le Mariam
ont se souvient en tout cas de cette
chercheuse franco-iranienne fariba
adelka parce qu'elle avait été
votre invité sur France 24 il y a deux
ans elle est toujours assignée à
résidence d'ailleurs à Téhéran privé de
liberté le cinéaste et opposant iranien
Jafar panaïe celui qui a fait taxi
Téhéran ce film formidable lui aussi a
été interpellé je crois qu'il est
condamné à je ne sais combien d'années 6
ans de prison c'est ça donc et cette
répression on peut dire qu'elle est
vraiment pas séparée la situation
internationale de l'Iran parce qu'en
fait ils sont aussi utilisés comme des
monnaies d'échanges par le régime
iranien il faut peut-être redonner un
peu de contexte il y a aussi Mohamed
rassoulouf qui a fait un film très beau
le diable j'ai plus le titre j'ai le
titre en personne bref il a fait un très
beau film lui aussi a été arrêté il y a
une dépression sur les cinéastes
notamment said roustaï qui a sorti le
très beau la loi de Téhéran et
dernièrement les frères de Leila qui
sublimissime lui il est sous pression
aussi parce que son film n'a pas été vu
il est interdit de diffusion en Iran il
y a une vraie pression effectivement sur
le monde artistique sur les cinéastes il
y a eu des arrestations de photographes
et un préservatif que vous devez
connaître Midak et Charlotte des
personnalités publiques connues
reconnues dans leur milieu il y a aussi
l'émergence d'un MiTo d'un mouvement
MiTo en Iran et toutes les personnes qui
en parlent sont arrêtées on leur prend
leur passeport on est interdit de sortir
du territoire en disant qu'il va elles
vont être jugées donc je veux dire
soudurecissement il est sur tout le
monde il est sur les femmes
effectivement les anonymes dans les rues
iraniennes mais aussi sur le monde
artistique il fait en fait on a
l'impression qu'il veut refermer le pays
on assiste à une ouverture soit San
Rohani avec nous un regard porté vers
l'ouest la fin des sanctions
occidentales un vrai espoir que on
puisse commercer avec les Européens que
l'Iran ne soit plus imparia et là on est
en train de refermer lire moi c'est
comme ça que je le vis en tout cas et
pendant que le pays s'embrasse et bien à
l'ONU le président iranien c'est montré
accusateur dans son discours à la
tribune de l'Assemblée des général des
Nations unies à New York hier il a
dénoncé donc Ibrahim raï ici deux poids
deux mesures des Occidentaux puisqu'il a
dit que en matière de droit des femmes
il a pointé par exemple le sort des
femmes autochtones du Canada ou celui
des Palestiniennes dans les territoires
occupés et il a aussi évoqué les
négociations sur le nucléaire iranien on
l'écoute
de chef du gouvernement de la République
islamique d'Iran jaffirme que l'Iran ne
cherche pas à obtenir l'arme nucléaire
et ses armes n'ont aucune place dans
notre doctrine
cela a été annoncé dans une fatwa
officielle du chef suprême
et tout cela se déroule dans un
environnement où les pays qui cherchent
à nous montrer injustement comme une
menace continue de poursuivre le
développement et les tests et ont donné
ces armes de destruction massive au
régime sionique
cet accord je vous faire intervenir
aussi en suite mais malheureusement la
finalisation tant espérée
iranien
parce que manifestement il y a une
pardon une obstruction iranienne
en fin de parcours qui qui prétexte
cette finalisation notamment sur le
refus de l'Iran de réponse sur un
dossier très sensible à la IH voilà
c'est ça il y a des enquêtes sur trois
sites qui ont été non déclarés où il y a
de l'uranium anthropique c'est-à-dire
d'origine humaine inexplicable autrement
que par des travaux secrets et là il va
demande c'est son rôle demande des
réponses justement
de l'existence de cette uranium
entropique et il y a un refus
catégorique manifestement de Téhéran qui
va jouer sur d'autres registres pour
finalement
différer c'est la finalisation d'un
accord est-ce qu'effectivement ils
peuvent avoir est-ce qu'ils ont la
possibilité de sortir une bombe
nucléaire pour faire simple les Iraniens
la bombe électeur en terme en termes de
d'uranium enrichis oui aujourd'hui
l'Iran est à 60% voire au-delà donc
l'Iran 90% et fabriqué une bombe ça et
donc c'est c'est en quelques semaines
enfin c'est faisable tout à fait à court
terme en revanche après il y a le
phénomène de la vectorisation c'est une
autre étape c'est à dire mettre un engin
façonné dans un vecteur pour pouvoir
mais sur le fond de l'Iran est devenu un
pays du seuil et c'est le problème c'est
qu'on ne reviendra pas en arrière on
n'est plus dans la situation 2015 l'Iran
à un savoir-faire qui a été capitalisé
sur lequel on ne reviendra pas même si
on mettait de côté les stocks d'uranium
enrichi et donc de ce point de vue là
liant à fessionne la doctrine de Obama à
l'époque de passion stratégiques elle
est parvenue au fait d'être
objectivement au seuil de l'arme
nucléaire en même temps oui
enfin ils disent que c'est la faute de
Donald Trump déjà qui est sorti de la
porte et les Européens aussi vous dites
bien sûr les Iraniens ils ont joué le
jeu ils ont ils se sont pliés à toutes
les exigences ils ont fermé 4/5 de
l'heure de leur centrale il y a une
vraie une vraie volonté que cet accord
est marché puis d'un coup Donald Trump a
décidé de sortir de cet accord les
Européens n'ont jamais eu le courage il
faut le dire je pense de contourner ses
sanctions américaines on n'avait pas ils
ont essayé quand même le sexe
et il y a un vrai sentiment d'amertume
en Iran de la part de vis-à-vis des
Européens et on a l'impression que les
Européens ont abandonné les Iraniens
donc à un moment donné ils ont attendu
attendu puis en 2019 sont dit voilà on a
aucune parce que cet accord il est
encore vivant pourquoi pas finalement il
le souhaitait au départ parce qu'ils
sont remis à
ne sont pas pressés de signer parce que
si c'est pour signer un accord dans deux
ans un nouveau président républicain a
lieu aux États-Unis qui ressort de cet
accord c'est inexplicable pour leur bas
élector et les en critiquer ça arrive
pendant 8 ans en disant qu'il était naïf
de faire confiance aux Américains s'ils
font la même chose aujourd'hui et en
plus ils sont pas pressés pourquoi
plusieurs raisons la guerre en Ukraine
ils attendent déjà de voir les
conséquences cet hiver pour les
Européens eux dans leur calcul ils
pensent être plutôt en position de force
et en plus la philosophie
du regard vers l'est du guide et de
réussite ça veut dire regarder vers la
Russie vers la Chine c'était le discours
de réussir un nouvel ordre mondial donc
il y a une part d'idéologie mais aussi
son pragmatique le prix du pétrole
augmente donc ils vendent quand même du
pétrologie chinois ils ont un peu plus
de revenus et il pense pouvoir réussir à
gagner un peu de temps et refaire un
calcul des rapports de force après les
élections mitaines aux Etats-Unis en
tout cas c'est intéressant c'est de
regarder la presse iranienne ce matin et
de voir donc les photos de Emmanuel
Macron et de et Brahim raï ici tous les
deux donc aux Nations Unies
manifestement la presse on a beaucoup
parlé
voilà on voit donc cette image
ça vous fait réagir justement resbane
Zaidi de voir Emmanuel Macron avec Rai
ici et comme ça en Une de la presse
iranienne
moi à mon avis quand j'ai vu que ils ont
en train de parler si Macron elle a
parlé pour que les femmes iranien avoir
le liberté égalité alors il dit qu'ils
en ont touché un mot enfin c'était pas
le meilleur du sujet c'était l'accord
sur une éclair on sait jamais que ils
ont discuté sur
exactement quel point mais j'espère que
soit parlé sur le liberté égalité pour
les femmes iraniens si ce soit ça à mon
avis que c'est à une chose positive
sinon
moi j'aimerais pas que
tu parles avec une dictature
vous le déplorez en fait exactement pour
comprendre que les conservateurs ils ont
très bien utilisé les images en disant
qu'il y aura ici a fait attendre Macron
il a une réponse très ferme sur la
situation des femmes et réussit la
partie à New York pour les pour ce genre
d'image aujourd'hui il a pas fait une
interview avec vous
imaginez la présentatrice de CNN il lui
demande aux États-Unis de de mettre un
voile pour l'internet
d'ailleurs sur CBS la journaliste
américaine avait mis le voile
devant le journaliste qui on a les
libertés pour les femmes et les femmes
qui choisissent sont tout ça pour ça
que c'est le haut qui a obligé de porter
le voile pour le journaliste alors ça
veut dire que même ici donc avec votre
interview il n'y a pas de liberté ça
veut dire qu'ils impôts ne le voit ils
imposent le voile partout donc ça veut
dire qu'ils utilisent Mariam c'est
intéressant ils utilisent finalement
cette entrevue entre le président
français et le président iranien
vraiment c'est le régime qui l'utilise
de son côté enfin on sa faveur la photo
alors à ce pas du tout en Iran je veux
dire on est face à une répression quand
même sanglante il y a des morts et il y
a le président d'une des plus grandes
démocraties au monde qui sert la main
pour sourire à Ibrahim
cette photo elle est très commentée
les accords de Vienne David Rigoulet et
rose en même temps c'est ce que dit
Emmanuel Macron qu'il l'a vu pour
évoquer cette cette négociations oui
mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu il y a eu un risque
d'instrumentalisation qui a été
stigmatisé justement par par les
Iraniens en disant bon voilà c'est
finalement ça sert plus à ici qu'à au
président Macron est-ce que l'influence
de l'Iran est plus importante
aujourd'hui puisqu'on parle question
internationale au Liban en Irak et en
Syrie David rigoleros bah elle est elle
demeure importante je dirais pas qu'elle
est plus importante parce qu'il y a une
forme de reflux contraint en réalité et
pas uniquement pour des raisons de
manque financier il y a eu l'assassinat
de soleil manie qui a été quand même
dont il a parlé d'ailleurs
3 janvier 2020 donc a été quand même
quelque chose qui a été un marqueur fort
un choc en niant mais pas seulement donc
redonner un peu le contexte assassiné
par les Américains et lui jeter le
symbole voilà donc le bras armé des
passe à l'étranger très présent en Irak
justement et où il a été assassiné à
Bagdad et donc c'était une réponse
américaine à un certain nombre de de
manifestations d'activisme de la part de
Téhéran et c'est vrai que depuis lors il
y a un espèce de statu quo qui s'est
fait il y a des l'Iran rencontre des
difficultés dans les pays qui sont
qui sur lesquels il avait une influence
très importante y compris au Liban
d'ailleurs il y a aussi des difficultés
quelles difficultés
parce qu'il y a toujours les sanctions
donc il y a un volet financier qui était
très large avant et qui s'est réduit
quand même de fait et puis et puis une
forme de nationalisme qui ressurgit dans
les pays arabes que ce soit en Irak même
au Liban qui fait que finalement ce qui
est perçu comme l'influence iranienne et
moins et vu beaucoup moins favorablement
qu'il y a une dizaine d'années on va
dire que ça peut-être justement entre
les pro iraniens
exactement voilà division des chiffres
en Irak faut dire que le général
solemuni il arrivait un peu à faire
union entre ces groupes cheat son
successeur il parle pas arabe comme lui
il a pas la même expérience sur le
terrain en Irak donc ça a été un coup
très dur au gardien de révolution alors
opération dans la région c'est aussi une
question de financement pourtant
pourcentage du PIB iranien c'est pour
l'armée pour leur action militaire dans
la région donc aujourd'hui avec la crise
économique forcément moins de
financement pour les groupes dans la
région voilà il brandit le portrait
justement du général Solène exactement
parce que le général soleimoni est très
apprécié par les conservateurs en Iran
et donc c'est tout un symbole en disant
que dans la rue elles sont en train de
manifester pour le voile et moi je
prends ce portrait à New York
vous qui aimez l'image là effectivement
on voit toute cette communication
politique de la part du président
iranien
la communication politique à travers les
images à travers la photo justement je
pense que
dans dans mon chemin et chemin mais que
je prends le photo il y a une chose que
je pense que pour montrer le photo en
Iran c'est un vraiment une grande comme
arme pour les correctement iraniens si
on fait attention dans toute la rue que
on voit le les photos des rameneries et
les autres complètement qui sont
importants comme Soleimani et c'est pour
ça que toujours c'est eux qui
utilisaient les photos comme une art
mais pour montrer que je pense que c'est
autre que tu trouves
l'effort les forces dans les photos et
il y a un côté que à mon avis c'est pour
ça que c'est aucune n'aime pas de
présenter beaucoup de photos qui sont
contre
la même de par exemple dans le cinéma
dans mon coeur des images exactement
c'est le photo c'est pour ça qu'ici eux
qu'il faut arrêter le photo qui sont
contre et fait le censure mais pour eux
qui montrent les photos je pense que ça
c'est la guerre des images est
importante d'ailleurs il y a une fête
aujourd'hui qui célèbre justement me
semble-t-il la victoire contre enfin en
tout cas la guerre en Iran Irak je
cherchais justement dans mes feuilles
exactement quel est qu'elle était cette
cette fête mais là aussi il y a des
images voilà on voit on voit les images
en ce moment là c'est une période de
deuil aussi c'est le début voilà le
début
de la Défense nationale quand la guerre
Iran Irak a débuté les années 80 oui
donc en 1980 donc ça voilà ce défilé
militaire qui a eu lieu donc aujourd'hui
donc on voit que ça historiquement c'est
important aussi pour eux de célébrer ce
type après faut rester nuancé dans le
sens où tous les Iraniens ont beaucoup
de respect pour les morts de la guerre
Iran Irak c'est des jeunes qui sont
partis défendent leur pays qui avaient
finalement le même courage que les gens
qui sont aujourd'hui dans la rue mais
c'est sûr que le régime
instrumentalisent leur mémoire à des
fins politiques mais en Iran dans
presque toutes les familles vous avez un
jeune qui a perdu sa vie lors de la
guerre en Irak et ce qui est je trouve
quand même vraiment inacceptable c'est
ce cette instrumentalisation par le
régime de leur mémoire
ce défiler enfin c'est à dire que quand
on est journaliste là-bas on a invité
donc j'avais filmé des images ou bien
très tôt le matin c'est une
démonstration de force mais comme
dans beaucoup de pays de la région en
Corée du Nord ou d'autres enfin sans
faire de parallèle mais oui c'est une
démonstration de force il joue sur le
souvenir c'est vrai que ça mobilise
quand même
ça mobilise une certaine partie ça
mobilise la partie qui vote pour Ibrahim
quand même une mémoire partagée qui
reste y compris pour les jeunes
générations il y a un respect quand même
pour ce qui s'est passé même si c'est
pas connu si ça a pas été vécu c'est là
où le régime est habile effectivement
parce qu'il est ravive ça oui il utilise
ça en sachant que ces mémoires partagées
et il peut jouer sur les différents
générationnels pour essayer de cimenter
même si le noyau dur c'est évidemment
bah les quinquagénaires enfin tous ceux
qui ont vécu cette période et en fait on
appelle ça la génération brûlée nation
sûreté cette génération qui est qui a
connu la guerre Iran Irak les privations
pendant 8 ans vous connaissez peut-être
mieux que moi oui parce que c'est la
époque de
il y a 30 ans comme ça avec c'est pour
ça que on dit Nestlé oui parce que dans
dans cette époque elle avait beaucoup de
contrôle et ils ont vraiment
dans cette époque il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui étaient contre c'est eux
qui a tué
c'était une génération qui a qui a vécu
les manquements qui a vécu les bombes
qui tombaient sur l'Iran et donc c'est
une génération perdue quoi oui c'est ça
alors on va revenir justement au
manifestations est-ce que Farid baïd
est-ce que c'est manifestation on voit
on voit déjà la répression mais est-ce
qu'elle pourrait venir à bout du régime
iranien je pense pas qu'il y aura un
changement de régime ou une révolution
dans deux semaines ou dans deux mois en
revanche faut pas penser ce que
j'entends de temps en temps que ce
mouvement de toute façon ne sert à rien
parce qu'il y aura une répression non à
chaque fois c'est un pas j'en suis
persuadé vers un changement profond vers
la liberté oui les manifestations de
toute façon on voit que manifestation
change de nature c'est de plus en plus
violent les gens sont de plus en plus en
colère faut pas croire que ça va mener à
rien mais faut pas non plus penser que
dans deux semaines il y aura un
changement de régime c'est un état très
structuré militaire sécurité ils ont
quand même une minorité entre guillemets
fanatique qui est prêt à tuer ils sont
religieux c'est une dictature religieuse
donc ils ont quand même leur partisans
mais il y a toute cette majorité on va
dire d'iranien de jeunes qui veut autre
chose et l'avenir leur appartient donc
un jour ça changera est-ce que ça sera
dans deux semaines je ne pense pas mais
ça change rien parce que ce qui est
incroyable Mariam c'est que ce régime
tiens toujours depuis 1979 43 ans donc
43 ans c'est 23 ans effectivement c'est
assez incroyable parce qu'il a il tient
alors quand même avec il a commencé avec
une guerre qui a duré 8 ans un embargo
plus d'une dizaine d'années de sanctions
et des mouvements et en fait c'est de
contestation
elles sont matées dans le sang on ferme
le pays et on revient à une vie normale
mais effectivement je pense qu'à chaque
contestation on on fait un petit pas
c'est peut-être un petit pas mais on
gagne certaines choses et de toute façon
je pense que les autorités ne peuvent
plus rester sourde face à une colère qui
est qui gagne tout le pays j'ai vu des
personnes âgées aussi qui sont qui sont
qui reste à côté de la jeunesse vous
savez personne âgées qui ont enlevé le
voile
80% de la population iranienne à une
trentaine d'années c'est-à-dire qu'elle
l'a connu que la République islamique et
elle ne veut plus de ses dictats et ça
la c'est un pays qui est très connecté
aussi sur un vers les réseaux sociaux
vers Internet et ça les autorités ne
peuvent plus faire comme si de rien
n'était il y a une gare de succession en
ce moment faut peut-être dire un mot
là-dessus David roubiolarose qui est la
succession de du guide se prime Ali
ramené donc c'est évidemment pas hasard
j'imagine que c'est une pression arrive
en ce moment en ce moment parce qu'il
est malade depuis longtemps il a disparu
des écrans la semaine dernière donc il y
a eu des spéculations sur sur son état
de santé il est revenu pour montrer
qu'il était toujours aux commandes etc
parce qu'évidemment c'est le la statue
du Commandeur c'est la pierre de autour
du Guide suprême c'est lui qui a tout
pouvoir
c'est lui qui effectivement imprime la
marque au nesame au système iranien
après les autres institutions
oui c'est lui qui dirige et en dernier
ressort c'est lui qui décide notamment
pour le nucléaire pas seulement ma femme
notamment pour nucléaire donc évidemment
le successeur la succession ils ont
c'est très opaque donc la succession
elle devrait se faire entre son fils
d'après ce que j'ai lu et pas tellement
pour succéder
même racine n'est pas forcément en odeur
de synthèse je dirais donc il y a la ça
sera l'assemblée des experts de toute
façon qui décidera et il y a beaucoup
d'inconnus c'est une variable à
plusieurs inconnus en réalité
je pense après si nous on est en train
de parler de ça ça veut dire que
forcément il pense aussi le problème non
j'ai pas forcément réessayer les il est
il manque de de charisme il parle pas
bien c'est pas un bon narrateur il est
pas charismatique moi je suis d'abord le
problème ça fait une dynastie ils ont
fait toute leur idéologie contre la
monarchie et là la République va devenir
une hiérarchie et une monarchie moi je
savais il a pas de présence politique
on le connaît mais on l'a jamais entendu
il a jamais de je pense qu'il parier
sera ici c'est pour ça qu'ils ont tout
fait pour qu'il devient président de la
République mais le problème c'est que il
a pas le niveau
candidats on ne sait pas ça va être une
surprise du chapeau
mais non mais effectivement ça va être
une vraie guerre de succession l'Iran
peut entrer dans une grave crise
politique parce que chacun va vouloir
défendre son pouvoir son influence tu
sais c'est un quand vous dites chacun on
parle quand même d'un petit noyau de
conservateur là
en fait
il y avait un moment donné les
spéculations selon laquelle cette
réplique islamique elle est passée sous
la main des des Gardiens de la
Révolution totalement alors juste il
faut expliquer ce que c'est au
téléspectateurs que nous regardent les
Gardiens de la Révolution les fameux
passent d'arrond donc en fait ce sont
des militaires qui sont c'est l'armée on
appelle l'économie aussi idéologique qui
tiennent 50% de l'économie on dit
peut-être beaucoup plus
remettre dans le contexte historique ils
ont été créés après la révolution parce
que le régime ne faisait pas confiance à
l'armée impériale du chat donc il
voulait créer même leur propre force de
l'ordre juste une petite nuance sur le
guide selon la Constitution iranienne
c'est possible d'avoir un conseil de
guidances c'est-à-dire trois personnes
qui forment un conseil et qui guide eux
le pays du rat sur Johnny ce sera
peut-être un voilà ça sera peut-être une
possibilité en tout cas c'est dans la
Constitution iranienne ça serait une
possibilité du coup ça serait peut-être
plus ouvert si il était trois au lieu
d'un si je puis dire raisin
si justement ils élargissent ce conseil
à trois personnes ça sera peut-être plus
ouvert
à mon avis que
non parce que c'est déjà ils ont
transféré leur idéologie pour continuer
de cette de leur chemin non donc ça
changera pas à mon avis de rigolo
enfin on reste dans le régime pour une
minorer une guerre fratricide on va dire
de la succession individuelle c'est sa
mutualiser succession dans un premier
temps ça pourrait être une option
effectivement j'évoquais le cadre
Inferni puisqu'il avait à l'époque il
avait évoqué effectivement la réforme
et qui est une espèce de voilà de trium
du coup est-ce qu'on est à un moment
justement un peu fragile en ce moment
qu'il y ait lié à cette histoire de
succession est-ce que ça pourrait
attiser encore des oppositions je pense
que le système se sent très vulnérable
vous avez une grande crise économique le
pays est quand même économiquement
paralysé complètement isolé du monde une
crise politique
souffre de légitimité politique il n'a
pas été élu c'était une nomination
présidentielle les Condes et les autres
candidats ont été filtrés donc réussi il
a faut oublier faut pas oublier que
réussisse aussi les années 80 ça aussi
les exécutions des opposants des années
80 c'est une crise politique le guide
âgé il est malade le système se sent
forcément vulnérable et d'ailleurs ça
peut être pour ça qu'on voit qu'il
réagissent de cette manière en ce moment
parce qu'ils doivent se sentir affaibli
la répression le moment où elle avait lu
est vraiment réussi c'est le taux le
plus bas de participation de toute la
République islamique c'est moins de 50%.
donc ça prouve bien que il n'y a plus il
n'y a plus aucune légitimité enfin les
présidents à sanani il y avait une vraie
mobilisation moi je me souviens de
bureau de vote qui permet à minuit
tellement les personnes aller voter
en s'ouvre sauf qu'effectivement là
c'était un simulacre d'élection les
jeunes les Iraniens ne sont même pas
déplacés aux urnes et encore 48%
peut-être que ce chiffre a été gonflé
vous avez un espoir vous que ça change
un jour rezvan et retourner dans votre
pays j'espère que oui j'espère seulement
s'il y a une fin du régime fin de régime
exactement j'espère et vous pensez
justement comme Farid Vahid que c'est
cumulatif c'est manifestations que au
bout d'un moment ça changera
bien sûr que toujours le manifestation
pour changer beaucoup de choses et ça
peut aider pour
réussir de
[Musique]
choses que les femmes et les hommes qui
vont avoir plus de liberté pour le
liberté dans le pays David rigole rose
vous vous êtes vous pensez que ça
changera un jour en Iran
structurellement est
condamnéologique qui joue en défaveur de
ceux qui sont au pouvoir de toute façon
mais comme vous y êtes toujours des
successeurs
d'ailleurs c'est une partie de ce qui
explique l'échec à la fois du Mouvement
Vert et de ce qu'on a appelé les
réformateurs il peut pas se transformer
de l'intérieur donc il a vocation entre
guillemets à tomber un jour ou l'autre
alors la question c'est quand c'est
toujours pareil comment mais ce type de
d'événement là et susceptible de
constituer un accélérateur quand même il
y a on sait jamais il peut y avoir des
points de bascule au niveau du pouvoir
non non mais au niveau de la l'onde de
choc qui traverse toute la société c'est
une crise sociétale c'est pas une crise
socio-économique là elle s'ajoute à la
crise économique mais profondément c'est
une crise sociétale sur ce qui fait
l'ADN du régime ce que vous disiez tout
simplement
je pense pas pas dans l'immédiat non
mais donc il est dans une impasse le
pouvoir mais ça changera forcément un
jour parce que c'est une anomalie parce
qu'on est face à une société qui veut
autre chose radicalement différente un
état qui donne quelque chose d'autre il
faut aussi comprendre l'histoire de
l'Iran l'Iran et un pays qui est
beaucoup beaucoup d'inacé beaucoup de
changements dynastie moi je vois un peu
la République islamique comme une
dynastie comme les autres qui changera
un jour merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été avec toi en tout cas les
manifestations continues on va suivre ça
de près merci beaucoup David rigoléroz
d'avoir été avec nous merci Mariam
Mariam kerza Farid vaïd et Merci à VOUS
resvan Zaidi merci à vous tous de vous
avoir
[Musique]